c'est un logement où la locataire va
quitté on va faire des petites choses
pour s'assurer comme boucher des trous
propriétaires de cet immeuble depuis une
dizaine d'années Véronique a appris les
travaux manuels du jour au lendemain ici
on va devoir l'ajuster comme ça quand on
a tout fait a pris sa retraite le prix
pour embaucher un ouvrier avait explosé
trouver un contracteur la désillusionné
comment ils font on sait pas quand ils
font donc je me suis dit tant qu'à payer
quelqu'un que je connais pas qui fait
des trucs qui sont pas tant difficiles à
mon avis je vais les faire moi-même
pourtant elle partait de loin manier la
perceuse représentée en réel défi elle
s'est donc tournée vers des cours de
rénovation pour apprendre les petits
travaux et réaliser de grosses économies
au moins pour 2000 dollars puis je pense
que en tout et pour tout ça nous a coûté
Stéphanie Lévesque s'est lancé dans les
ateliers de rénovation il y a plus d'une
décennie un cours de trois heures coûte
entre 65 et 100 dollars
la demande pour ses formations a bondit
d'environ 25% entre 2019 et 2022 la
pénurie de main d'oeuvre partout et ça
serait ça énormément dans le milieu de
l'industrie de la construction et
l'explosion des coûts donc ces deux
combines là ont fait en sorte que les
gens voulaient se réapproprier en fait
leur intérieur les dépenses sont
rénovation résidentielles ont atteint
des sommets au Québec en 2021 il devrait
se chiffrer à 17 milliards de dollars en
donc même chose coup franc on filme une
capsule sur la pose du plancher de bois
franc les cours de Stéphanie Ford de
leur popularité emprunte le virage web
dans le sens où la langue tourne vers
soi ils sont suivis en ligne au 4 coins
du Québec le projet en partenariat avec
l'entreprise les filles de la
construction et destiné aux femmes
désireuses de vaincre les stéréotypes
féminins en matière de rénovation on est
l'impression que c'est à faire de gars
on se fait souvent traiter comme des
petites filles ou comme des petites
madames dans des situations comme ça
c'est honnêtement super genre
dévalorisant et ça nous fait sentir
qu'on est justement pas au bon endroit
puis qu'on est pas capable mais au-delà
des économies les travaux manuels
sont-ils vraiment pour tout le monde je
crois sincèrement que oui c'est
accessible à tout le monde mais non ce
n'est pas tout le monde qui aime ça
c'est devenu une passion oui vos vrai
j'adore ça c'est des reliques à joint
l'utile à l'agréable ces connaissances
lui permettront à l'avenir de mieux
négocier avec les contracteurs parce que
je veux savoir de quoi je parle je vais
être capable de challenger la personne
ça me coûter moins cher des économies
qui lui permettront de réaliser
elle-même de plus grands projets ici
Jean-Philippe
Radio-Canada Montréal